let's take a closer look at this and
other stories with Sahil Kapoor national
political reporter for Bloomberg News
good morning good morning does the
president have the ammunition he needs
to fire Rosenstein if he wants to well
in theory if he decides to look at this
in view this as Rosenstein actually
trying to make a move against him then
maybe it depends on what's going on in
his mind but we know they're differing
interpretations of this there are other
sources in the room who was suggested
that there was a sarcastic it was a flip
comment he was shooting down McCabe's
suggestion of an investigation what do
you want me to do Andy wear a wire
not that he was seriously suggesting you
know going against the president we've
obviously heard in Paul's report that
also Rosen Stein has denied this but
what would his removal if that happen
mean for the Russia investigation it
would be very significant Rosen Stein is
the linchpin of the Russia investigation
he appointed Bob Muller he oversees it
because Attorney General Jeff Sessions
is recused from that investigation so
the question is who would be you know
who would be replacing him and what
would that person do president Trump we
know is strongly against this
investigation he's increasingly soured
on it so he may want to pick somebody
who you know has a similar view which is
why he'd have trouble confirming them
let's turn now to Brett Kavanaugh as
confirmation a lot or a little happened
overnight as I recall but bring us up to
date on what all of that means big
picture they seem to be moving toward a
resolution where dr. Christine Blasi
Ford testifies in the Senate Brett
Kavanaugh will have to say as well
respond to the allegations against him
this could happen this week around
Wednesday or so but the negotiations are
not final they're still figuring out the
terms of it who's gonna be in the room
how many rounds of questioning that sort
of thing but its enormous ly significant
because this is gonna probably determine
whether or not he gets a seat on that
Supreme Court for 30 to 40 years the
political stakes are high here too with
the midterms living so closely aren't
they they certainly are and this whole
conversation this whole debate threatens
to to douse gasoline on an already
raging me to movement where you see
suburban professional college-educated
women are mobilized that's the threatens
to intensify that and some of the
rhetoric coming from Republicans
including Senator McConnell that you'd
played is being used by Democrats to
fuel that he suggested yesterday that he
has the votes already to confirm him do
you think he does well I think it was
more of a pressure tactic than a
prediction he doesn't control the votes
of people like susan collins and lisa
murkowski if he did the ACA would be
repealed
he's trying to keep the heat on he's
he's telling his you know conservative
allies don't let up on this we still
need to push forward on this and you
know they do respond to pressure so
they're gonna be feeling a lot of it
from both sides Anthony mentioned the
midterms we've seen President Barack
Obama has been out on the campaign trail
as well in a state like Pennsylvania
which is so key we look forward to the
midterm elections and we know how high
the stakes are but what kind of impact
does the president need to have there
well the stakes are huge the voters are
going to decide which party runs the
house that's the power of the purse
power to oversee the president it's
essentially a binary choice between a
party that's going to be standing by the
president and defending him and trying
to carry out his agenda and a party
that's going to be adversarial and
confrontational toward him and yes I
think President Obama's trying to get
involved
tell the Democrats this is important you
need to show up is that enough
well the tide is is in favor of
Democrats right now the president's
approval rating is low and the generic
ballot which asks voters which party
they prefer to control Congress is
strong for Democrats but they need to
turnout and that's why President Obama
isn't trying to make that closing
argument so we'll see and LU of all of
that that we've been discussing have the
Republicans lost their key important
messaging issue especially on something
like tax cuts right so my colleague and
I obtained an internal Republican
National Committee poll where they they
you know tested voter opinion on their
tax law which is a signature legislative
achievement of this Congress and what
they found is that public opinion is
divided overall when you simply ask
favorable unfavorable but by two-to-one
margin Americans believe that the tax
law benefits large corporations and the
wealthy over the middle class that's
completely contradictory to their
message that kind of explains why they
pivoted off the messaging trying to
solve the tax cuts and move toward
culture wars things like immigration and
crime and nativism which do you know
really mobilize the conservative base
never a dull day so Kippur thank you so
much thank you